.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Sorry, können Sie mir sagen,
ob man da durchgehen kann?
Meine Augennerven
sind wie explodiert.
Wenn man hier unten ankommt,
geht es nicht weiter, oder?
Irgendwann hatte ich die Aussage,
in drei Monaten sei ich blind.
Es wird wärmer.
Hier hat es Textilien.
(App) Strumpfhose.
Dass man sich das immer zurechtlegen
und den Mut zusammenkratzen muss,
um selbstständig zu sein
und darauf zu vertrauen,
dass das Leben mich trägt ...
Wie gelingt ein gutes Leben,
auch mit Behinderung?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Guten Morgen, Frau Schläfli.
Grüezi, Frau Arnet.
Es ist laut.
- Jetzt ist es hell.
Nein, laut.
- Laut?
Gehen wir weiter? Gut.
- Ja.
Andrea Schläfli ist früh unterwegs.
So hat sie genügend Zeit,
um den Weg zu ihrem heutigen
Arbeitsort zu finden.
Sie sind
nicht so häufig in Andelfingen.
Wie orientieren Sie sich?
Für mich ist das Leben
häufig ein "Memory"-Spiel.
Hier bin ich immer etwas unsicher.
Aber wenn ich dort bin, weiss ich,
wo ich abzweigen muss.
Was heisst das, ein "Memory"-Spiel?
Erinnerungen?
Ja, sich daran erinnern,
wo es ungefähr durchgeht.
Dabei hilft mir schon,
dass ich entspannt genug bin.
Wenn ich es gar nicht weiss,
werde ich sehr nervös.
Können Sie mir beschreiben,
was Sie wirklich sehen?
Ich weiss es jeweils selber nicht.
Auf einem Auge sehe ich gar nichts.
Und auf dem anderen
sehe ich Flecken,
die sich immer bewegen.
Darum ist manchmal nicht klar,
was ich sehe.
Ich habe einen Signalstock,
der kürzer ist.
Damit die Leute v.a. sehen,
dass ich sie nicht sehe.
Ah, Sie brauchen den nicht,
um zu tasten?
Manchmal schon,
wenn ich ganz unsicher bin,
ob es einen Tritt hat oder so.
Andrea Schläfli arbeitet als Auf-
tritts- und Kommunikationstrainerin.
Heute bei der Gebäudeversicherung
des Kantons Zürich.
Hat es irgendwo einen Knopf,
um die Storen raufzulassen?
Diese Tätigkeit hat sie schon
ausgeübt, als sie noch gesehen hat.
Keine Ahnung. Oder ist es hier?
So.
Wenn man Ihnen zuschaut,
käme man nicht auf die Idee,
dass Sie sehbehindert sind.
- Das höre ich sehr häufig.
Das höre ich wirklich häufig.
Ja ...
Ist das Training?
Hm!
Vielleicht auch der starke Wille.
Und wenn ich
einen Raum abgescannt habe,
bewege ich mich einfach darin
und mache.
Hoi, Joli.
- Timmis, hoi.
Hoi, Timmis. Ui!
- Oliver.
Oli, Oliver. Timmis.
Heute trainiert Andrea Schläfli
Feuerwehrleute aus dem Kanton Zürich.
Der Inhalt erhält ein Gewicht
in seiner Gesamtwirkung.
Im Idealfall ...
Die Zahlen variieren etwas.
Aber es sind ungefähr 6 %.
* Lachen *
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Ich bin von der Feuerwehr Schlieren.
Ich nehme manchmal wahr, wenn jemand
dasteht und einen Auftritt hat ...
Ich glaube, das sieht man gar nicht,
aber ich spüre,
dass die Knie zittern
oder sie
die Zehen in den Schuhen bewegen.
Ja, genau.
- Schon fast ein siebter Sinn.
Ja, es ist eine Kombination, genau.
Ist es vielleicht von Vorteil,
dass Sie
nicht nur mit den Augen wahrnehmen?
Ja. Ich bin an einem Punkt,
wo ich sage, das sei ein Vorteil.
V.a. für die Art von Beruf.
Wir lassen uns so schnell blenden.
Und wenn ich nicht einfach
nur die Fassade abscannen kann,
nehme ich vermutlich
noch anderes wahr.
Andrea Schläfli lebt in Winterthur.
Sie ist Single
und führt ihren Haushalt allein.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich
darauf angewiesen,
dass immer
alles am gleichen Ort steht?- Immer.
Es ist ganz schlimm,
wenn jemand umräumt.
Aber ja, das kommt manchmal vor.
Ca. zwei- ...
... bis dreimal pro Jahr
hilft mir eine Freundin beim Putzen.
Sie räumt die Sachen
halt irgendwie ein,
was man ihr nicht übelnehmen kann,
aber ich muss dann alles an
den richtigen Platz zurückstellen.
Andrea Schläfli lebt ohne IV-Rente.
Sie will sich ihren Lebensunterhalt
selbst verdienen.
Sie sind schon auf viel Goodwill
ihres Umfelds angewiesen, oder?
Am Anfang
ist das eine grosse Herausforderung.
Zu sagen, dass man Hilfe braucht.
Und bei was.
Jedes Mal,
wenn man so etwas formuliert,
kommt vielleicht auch
wie eine Gefühlswelle mit,
dass ich mir leidtue, weil ich
wieder um Hilfe fragen muss.
Vorher konnte ich das ja
und jetzt nicht mehr.
* Scheppern *
Oh!
Pardon.
- Entschuldigung.
Ich sehe halt nichts auf der Seite.
So.
Andrea Schläflis Leben
mit Sehbehinderung
begann vor bald zehn Jahren.
In der Nacht waren ihre
Sehnerven richtiggehend explodiert.
Ich wachte an dem Morgen auf
und sagte zu meinem Partner:
"Ich sehe nichts mehr."
Rückblickend stimmte
diese Formulierung damals nicht.
Ich sah damals noch mehr,
als ich jetzt sehe.
Aber gefühlt war es so.
Ich wachte auf und sah nichts mehr.
Diese Art der Erblindung
ist äusserst selten.
Ihre Ärzte staunten darum
v.a. über die medizinische Sensation,
ohne Andrea Schläfli
jedoch zu helfen.
Diese musste zusehen, wie ihr
Sehvermögen mehr und mehr zurückging.
Ich kann mich
an Sequenzen erinnern.
Ich sass da und wartete darauf,
dass ein Arzt oder eine Ärztin
Zeit hat,
und starrte auf meine Schuhspitzen.
Ich machte abwechslungsweise das
eine und dann das andere Auge zu.
Ich testete, was ich noch sah.
Und über die Woche hinweg
erlebte ich,
dass ich irgendwann mit dem linken
Auge den Fuss nicht mehr sah.
So.
* Meditative, nachdenkliche Klänge *
(Weinend) Ich hatte einfach Angst.
Irgendwann wollte ich nicht mehr.
Irgendwann dachte ich:
"Ich habe keine Kraft mehr."
"Wofür soll ich mich
zu all diesen Terminen schleppen?"
"Der Typ will meinen Schädel
aufschneiden. Halleluja."
"Wer macht denn da eine
'Frankenstein'-Verfilmung?"
Ja ...
Ich dachte einfach:
"Ich springe irgendwo runter."
Andrea Schläfli suchte Hilfe
in alternativen Heilmethoden
und reiste in eine
ayurvedische Augenklinik in Indien.
Dort konnte man das Fortschreiten
der Erblindung zwar stoppen,
ihr Sehvermögen
kam aber auch dort nicht zurück.
In diesem Spital
hatte es einen ganz alten Arzt.
Der war irgendwie
auf dem Klinikgelände unterwegs.
Fast wie ein Geist.
Er tauchte dann irgendwo auf
oder so.
Und ich dachte: "Ja, ein Arzt."
Er hatte
diese wunderbare Angewohnheit ...
... einmal pro Tag
in mein Zimmer zu kommen.
Ich hörte ihn nie kommen.
Ich spöttelte manchmal,
er materialisiere
durch die Wände durch.
Irgendwann merkte ich dann,
dass er im Zimmer steht.
Und er schaute mich einfach an.
Dieser alte Arzt sollte an Andrea
Schläfli noch ein Wunder vollbringen.
Doch davon später.
Ich sehe hier
z.B. den Trottoirrand gut.
Dem gehe ich nach
und schaue nach unten.
Bis ich
bei der taktilen Markierung lande.
Und Sie warten hier, damit
der Buschauffeur Sie sieht.- Ja.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi. Ich steige beim Pilz aus.
Hauptbahnhof.
- Ja.- Danke.
Andrea Schläfli bewegt sich versiert
im öffentlichen Raum.
Aber: Sie sei stets
etwas am Hochstapeln, sagt sie mir.
Ganz viele von uns
bemühen sich wahnsinnig,
um Dinge auswendig zu lernen.
Dann wirkt das so souverän
und man kann sich fast vormachen,
das sei nicht wichtig oder ...
... wir könnten das ja,
das sei kein Problem.
Hier
könnte man aber auch was anzeigen.
Zu keinem Eingang
führt hier etwas hin.
Ich weiss wirklich nicht,
wo der Schalter ist.
Das würde ich mir wünschen.
Schneidet man sich
also auch ins eigene Fleisch,
wenn man so viel leistet
mit Auswendiglernen usw.?
Genau, aber
das Leben ist sonst so mühsam ...
Ich müsste hier
wieder jemanden "belästigen"
und fragen,
ob sie mir helfen können.
"Können Sie mir helfen,
den Schalter zu finden?"
"Können Sie mir helfen ..."
Man müsste ja Tickets rauslassen
und dann müsste man sehen,
dass die Nummer dran ist.
All das, was gefordert ist, nämlich,
dass wir Betroffenen selbstständig
sein können, ist dann nicht gegeben.
Sorry, können Sie mir sagen,
ob man da durchgehen kann?
Sehen Sie das?
Wie?
- Kann man hier durchgehen?
Ob Sie da durchkommen?
Gehen Sie besser auf die Seite.
Okay.
- Sie können mit mir mitkommen.
Ich muss sowieso dahin.
- Gut, danke vielmals. Merci.
Wenn Sie mit mir mitkommen ...
Vorsicht. Aufgepasst.
Wollen Sie sich an mir festhalten?
- Aha. Wow! Danke vielmals.
Bitte schön. Vorsichtig.
Hier geht es durch.
Vorsicht. Aufpassen.
- Ist gut.
Wow!
- Ich muss jetzt rein.
Kann ich Sie so lassen?
- Das ist gut, danke.
Schönen Tag.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Entschuldigung, darf ich Sie stören?
- Ja?
Darf ich da durch?
- Entschuldigung. Tut mir leid.
Hier hat es gar keine Leitlinie mehr.
Genau. Es ist leider
an vielen Bahnhöfen so,
dass es gar nichts hat.
Ich nehme die Wand wahr.
Für mich ist es toll,
wenn ich der Wand nachgehen kann.
Ich weiss, dass ich nach vorne muss,
bis ganz am Schluss
und dann links nach oben.
Auch auswendig gelernt.
Achtung.
Ich finde es anstrengend.
Wenn dann so ein Moment kommt,
wo einen plötzlich jemand anfasst,
der helfen will,
aber kein Wort sagt ...
Das passiert halt manchmal.
Dass ich
aus dem Weg gezogen werde oder so.
Aber da erschrecke ich mich so ...
Ich weiss,
dass die Leute es gut meinen,
aber im ersten Schreck
fauche ich sie dann an.
Ich finde das so schlimm,
dass mich jemand so drausbringt,
wenn innerlich
eh schon alles so macht.
Zurück zum alten Arzt in Indien.
Irgendwann sagte er jeweils:
"You must happy."
Ich lag weinend in meinem Bett.
Ich haderte mit mir
und meinem Leben,
mit allen Abschieden, die ich
in meinem Leben schon nehmen musste.
Und dann steht der da und sagt:
"You must happy."
Ich hätte in erwürgen können.
Was andere im Vorbeigehen machen,
ist für die 52-Jährige
ein Spiessrutenlauf.
Ich weiss, dass ich da rüber muss.
Hier wird es kalt.
Hier hat es Jogurt oder so.
Ah, es wird wärmer.
Hier hat es Textilien.
Ja ... Hei, ei, ei.
Strumpfhosen kaufen im Supermarkt,
z.B.
Mit ihrer Mutter hat sie den Laden
einen ganzen Vormittag lang
rekognosziert.
Es wäre super, wenn jemand
hier wäre, der hier arbeitet.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Es gibt eine App.
Die heisst "Seeing AI".
Also "Seeing Eye"
und "Artificial Intelligence".
Und die sollte mir vorlesen.
(App) Strumpfhose.
Strumpfhos... Strumpfhos...
Strumpfhose.
Aha.
Und welche Farbe?
Kannst du es lesen?
- (App) Anthrazit. Anthrocites.
Sie sehen also keine Farben.
Nein, Farben sehe ich nicht.
Und wenn sie so hängen,
weiss ich auch nicht,
ob sie vielleicht durchmischt sind.
(App) Coco.
Hat es da noch andere Farben?
Ist dieses Anthrazit wirklich grau?
Ist das grau oder bräunlich?
Es ist wirklich grau.
- Okay. Nein, das mag ich nicht.
Was haben wir hier?
Bron-tse.
- Bron-tse ...
Es war nicht "Bron-tse",
sondern "Bronze".
Hat sich Ihr Verhältnis
zu Ihrem Äusseren verändert,
seit Sie sehbehindert sind?
Ich bin dankbar, wenn mich jemand
auf Flecken aufmerksam macht.
Oder wenn jemand sagt, ich sollte
ein T-Shirt nicht mehr anziehen.
Das müsse in die Altkleidersammlung.
Darüber bin ich froh.
Ich habe natürlich
schon den Wunsch ...
... nicht
irgendwie ungepflegt auszusehen.
Ja, ich möchte nach wie vor
im Berufsleben unterwegs sein.
Das ist mir schon wichtig.
Ich nehme die, die vor mir ist.
Grüezi.
Und dann steht der da und sagt:
"You must happy."
Ich hätte in erwürgen können.
Ich argumentierte dann auch mit ihm:
"Ja, aber ..."
Ich kommunizierte ihm mein Elend,
mein Leid und mein Selbstmitleid.
Er müsse das doch verstehen.
Er könne doch nicht sagen,
ich müsse glücklich sein.
Und dieses "Spiel"
machten wir jeden Tag.
Dann stand er wieder da und sagte:
"You must happy."
Andrea Schläfli ist Sekundarlehrerin,
Theaterpädagogin, Kulturmanagerin.
Bei ihrer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit
muss ihr Hörsinn
den Sehsinn weitgehend ersetzen.
Jetzt habe ich hier
"Der unendliche Augenblick".
Das ist das Buch.
(App) "... Welt- und Menschenbild
der Moderne,
das in der Maxime der Aufklärung
seinen Ausdruck fand."
Es braucht viel Konzentration,
so einen Text zu hören.
Ich muss mir v.a.
sehr präzise aufschreiben ...
... welche Textstellen
ich wichtig finde.
Dann muss ich mir
die Minute aufschreiben.
Und das Kapitel.
Dann gebe ich das der Person,
die auch Lektoratssachen
für mich macht.
Ich gebe ihr die Print-Version
und die Zeitangaben.
Ich sage z.B., dass im Kapitel 9
die Stelle
mit ungefähr diesem Wortlaut steht.
Damit man sie dann
präzise zitieren kann.
Man könnte auch sagen,
ich solle selber lesen.
Das mache ich teilweise auch.
Aber
bei einer ganzen Publikation ...
... ist das für mich einfach
so unglaublich anstrengend,
wenn ich das
alles hier lesen müsste ...
Dann ist es eher so ...
Also, hier kann man vergrössern,
und da legt man das Buch darunter.
Damit kann man rumfahren.
So kann man es physisch sehen.
Das ist etwas zu klein.
Hier könnte ich lesen.
Ich kann auch mit Stiften markieren,
wenn ich das möchte.
Aber ein ganzes Buch so zu lesen,
finde ich sehr anstrengend.
Zürich, Ende Oktober 2022.
Menschen mit Behinderung
tauschen sich mit Vertretern
der kantonalen Verwaltung aus.
(Mann) Eins, zwei, drei.
- Es ist zu laut.
Zu laut?
- Ja.
2014 hat die Schweiz
die UNO-Behindertenrechtskonvention
unterzeichnet.
Umgesetzt wurde davon wenig.
Wo spüren Sie
am meisten Diskriminierung?
Uff!
Wirklich auf allen Ebenen,
die die Konvention berücksichtigt.
Die Schulhäuser sind schon nicht so,
dass die Kinder
integriert werden könnten.
Und, und, und, und, und.
- Sie wollen gar nicht aufzählen.
Das wird direkt episch.
Gerade letzte Woche
war ich auf einer Webseite
und wollte
eine Kontaktanfrage machen.
Am Schluss setzte ich brav den Haken
bei "Ich bin kein Roboter".
Dann ging ein Fenster auf.
Und da erschienen 16 verschwommene,
körnige Fotos
in Briefmarkengrösse
auf dem Bildschirm,
und man müsse die
mit Fussgängern anklicken.
Das kann ich nicht selber.
Meine Selbstständigkeit
ist eingeschränkt.
Da war jemand am Werke, der keinen
Gedanken daran verschwendet hat.
Moderatorin der sog. Partizipations-
konferenz des Kantons Zürich
ist Andrea Schläfli.
Okay.
Und dann den.
Wir brauchen Leute, die verstehen,
wie es ist, in einer
kantonalen Verwaltung zu arbeiten.
Also, für öffentliche Aufgaben
verantwortlich zu sein.
Wir brauchen Leute, die moderieren
und einen Dialog
zwischen verschiedenen Disziplinen
fördern können,
zwischen Verwaltungsangestellten
und Betroffenen.
Und wir brauchen jemanden,
der etwas von Behinderung versteht.
Andrea Schläfli versteht
wahnsinnig viel von allen dreien.
Darum ist sie die Idealbesetzung.
... auf die Bühne.
Andrea, vielen Dank.
Grüezi.
* Applaus *
Grüezi. Ich freue mich unglaublich,
dass ich heute Nachmittag
mit Ihnen hier sein darf.
Wir alle wissen:
Es gibt so viele Fragestellungen,
die jetzt für den Kanton Zürich
zu lösen sind.
Die für jede Gemeinde
zu lösen sein werden.
Es ist an uns, da den Impuls
für kreative und inspirierte
Lösungen zu geben.
Das ging eine Weile.
Wir machten so weiter und es
ging immer um "You must happy".
Und je länger es ging,
desto mehr ...
... Leichtigkeit gab mir das.
Das ist verrückt.
Man könnte jetzt fragen:
"Was? Ist das zynisch gemeint?"
Jedenfalls kam der wunderbare Tag,
der magische Moment ...
... als er
in meinem Zimmer stand ...
... und sagte:
"Now I feel it."
Und raus.
- Und raus in die Sonne.
Juhu.
- Voilà.
So schön.
Mit ihrer Freundin Doris Stalder
teilt Andrea Schläfli
ihre Begeisterung fürs Wandern.
Doris Stalder ist -
medizinisch gesehen - blind,
hat aber noch
einen minimalen Sehrest.
Dann
studieren wir mal diesen Wegweiser.
Der ist etwas doof.
- Saublöd, mit der Sonne.
Das ist etwas schwierig.
Ich muss so stehen, dass die Sonne
hinter dem Wegweiser ist.
Hat es wieder eine Farbe,
die ich nicht sehe?- Nein.
Da unten ist eine Zahl.
Genau.
Ist das der?
- Das muss der Jurahöhenweg sein.
Wenn ich Fotos mache, weiss ich
nicht so genau, was drauf ist.
Aber das ist ja egal.
Ihr seid ein hübsches Paar.
Das Fotografieren ist so eine Sache.
Doris sagte mal:
"Manchmal denke ich,
ich fotografiere eine schöne Blume,
dann war es
aber ein Robidog-Säckchen."
Jetzt ... Ich glaube,
es geht hier durch, oder?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Oder da? Ich sehe nichts.
- Da geht es nicht hin.
Doris Stalder erblindete Mitte 20.
Ich glaube wirklich,
was Doris sieht und was ich sehe,
das ergänzt sich ziemlich gut.
Weil ich im Zentrum noch was sehe.
- Genau.
Aber ich sehe keine Farben,
du dafür schon.
Dann setzt sich das so zusammen.
Sogar auf Augenhöhe.
Wir gehen zuerst
Richtung Balmfluechöpfli
und dann Richtung Röti.
- Genau.
Sie haben gesagt,
es sei nicht gefährlich,
aber hier geht es steil runter.
Wenn ich sorgfältig
einen Fuss vor den nächsten setze,
ist der Abgrund nicht wichtig
für mich.
Was ist das Vergnügen für Sie beide?
Also, ich ergänze einfach noch.
Ich sehe auf der Seite nichts.
Ich habe gar nicht gemerkt,
dass es runtergeht.
Ich folge einfach dem Weg.
Für mich ist das Vergnügen darin,
draussen zu sein,
zu atmen, zu hören.
Z.B. das Bächlein vorher.
Einfach in der Natur zu sein
und zu merken,
wie die Bewegung in der Natur
mich auflädt.
Doris Stalder
arbeitet als medizinische Masseurin,
hat mit 50
ein Soziologiestudium absolviert,
fährt Tandem und spielt Golf.
Doris Stalder gibt Ihnen Mut.
Mut wofür?
Ein Schlüsselsatz, den sie mir
bei unserer ersten Begegnung
ausserhalb der Skitourenwoche
gesagt hat, war für mich:
"Wenn ich etwas wirklich will,
überlege ich mir immer,
wie ich das
für mich möglich machen kann."
Das ist ein Schlüsselsatz.
Zu merken,
dass es eben nicht darum geht,
dass man etwas nicht kann.
Dann fängt man halt an,
rundherum zu bauen
und zu schauen,
wie es denn möglich ist.
Solche Dinge machen mir Mut.
Ich sage immer: "Ich habe kein
anderes Leben. Ich habe nur das."
Mein Ziel ist, aus dem,
was ich zur Verfügung habe,
möglichst viel Positives zu ziehen.
Und
nicht defizitorientiert zu leben.
Wir sind
schon höher als der Weissenstein.
Ja.
Genau.
Wow!
Super.
Sie haben
schon so manchen Gipfel erklommen,
seit Sie die Sehbehinderung haben.
Worauf sind Sie am stolzesten?
Ich habe mir das noch nie
mit dem Begriff Stolz ...
... überlegt.
Ich bin stolz,
das überlebt zu haben.
Dass Sie damals nirgends
runtergesprungen sind.- Genau.
* Ruhige Musik *
Er sagte mir irgendwann
so eindrücklich: "Schau."
"Wenn du in der Energie bleibst,
in der du bist,
denkst du,
du hättest auch nur einen Funken,
der etwas heilen kann?"
Und ...
"Denkst du, du hättest
auch nur einen Funken Ausstrahlung,
der macht, dass irgendjemand
gerne in deiner Nähe ist?"
Ja.
Sieben Jahre
arbeitete Andrea Schläfli
als Kulturvermittlerin
bei der Stadt Winterthur.
2016 kündigte sie frustriert.
Sie hätten sich bei diesem Schriftzug
gewünscht, man nähme ein L weg.
"Superbock". Warum?
Ich finde es unglaublich schlimm,
dass eine öffentliche Verwaltung
einer so grossen Stadt
im Jahr 2015 einen Neubau bezieht,
der nicht barrierefrei ist.
Ich war manchmal
wirklich so frustriert und fand,
das sei ein Superbock
und kein Superblock.
Gerne hätte ich gefilmt,
wie Andrea Schläfli
und der Winterthurer Stadtpräsident
diese Frage diskutieren.
Doch dieser will mich nur ohne seine
ehemalige Angestellte empfangen.
Ich kann den Vorwurf
nicht ganz verstehen.
Der Bau
wurde von der Grundeigentümerin
gemäss SIA-Norm 500 gebaut.
Das ist hindernisfreies Bauen.
Wir machten im Januar 2016
noch selber eine Begehung,
auch mit Mitgliedern
der Behindertenkonferenz Zürich.
Dort wurden Dinge festgestellt,
die wir nachbessern mussten.
Das haben wir in die Wege geleitet.
Ich denke,
wir haben darauf reagiert.
Auch wir fanden, dass man
noch etwas verbessern könnte.
Wir haben
gewisse Massnahmen ergriffen.
Daher sagte ich damals,
dass wir ein behindertengerechtes
Verwaltungsgebäude haben.
Trotz Nachbesserungen -
beim Blindenleitsystem z.B. -
besteht
auch heute noch Handlungsbedarf.
Hier bräuchte es
auch eine durchgehende Leitlinie,
damit man beim Aussteigen
oder Warten merkt,
dass man wirklich beim Bus ist.
Da vorne
hört die Linie eben einfach auf.
Die müsste ganz sicher ...
Letztlich müsste sie
zur Bushaltestelle führen.
Es ist völlig unklar,
warum sie hier einfach aufhört.
Die findet man
einfach von dort her nicht.
Aber, Frau Schläfli:
Es hat 4 % Sehbehinderte
in der Schweizer Bevölkerung.
Das würde enorme Kosten generieren,
wenn man das alles so machen müsste.
Ist das nicht überrissen?
Die Frage
nach der Verhältnismässigkeit.
Ja ... Die finde ich sehr schwierig,
weil ich sie als zynisch empfinde.
Wir sprechen über Menschenrechte.
Wir sprechen über den Auftrag
einer öffentlichen Verwaltung.
Entweder ist sie öffentlich oder
man möchte intern Fussball spielen.
Menschenrechte
sind nicht verhandelbar.
Ob die 5 m noch so unglaublich
viel mehr gekostet hätten,
wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Ihre Erfahrungen
bei der Stadt Winterthur
schmerzen Andrea Schläfli bis heute.
Ich hätte mir so sehr gewünscht,
dass irgendein Kopierer
zur Verfügung steht,
der keinen Touchscreen hat.
Damit ich eben nicht immer
die Assistentin des Bereichs Kultur
fragen muss, ob sie mir beim
Kopieren oder Scannen helfen könnte.
Sie machte das
mit unendlicher Liebe und Geduld,
aber ich habe doch das Bedürfnis,
meine Arbeit selber zu machen.
Ich habe mit Technikern gesprochen.
Da hat sich einer erdreistet,
weil er dachte, er sei lustig,
und meinte, ich solle doch
mit Tipp-Ex eine Markierung machen.
Es gab unglaublich viele Etappen,
an denen ich sagte,
wie gross meine Not ist.
Es gibt bei der Stadt Winterthur
ja eine Diversity-Beauftragte.
Ich suchte auch mit ihr das Gespräch
und erhielt keine Unterstützung.
Dass man sich das immer zurechtlegen
und den Mut zusammenkratzen muss,
um selbstständig zu sein
und darauf zu vertrauen,
dass das Leben mich trägt ...
Manchmal
ist das wahnsinnig anstrengend.
* Melancholische Musik *
Manchmal ist das enorm frustrierend.
Man ist manchmal
auch hin- und hergerissen,
ob man wieder
den Finger draufhalten soll.
Ja.
Ist es wirksam,
wenn ich mich wieder einsetze?
Wenn quasi das Gegenüber,
also Entscheidungsträger
und Entscheidungsträgerinnen finden,
wir würden wieder
mit einer Maximalforderung kommen.
Man muss sich zwischendurch
auch Sorge tragen und sagen:
"Heute mag ich nicht."
"Morgen dann wieder."
* Melancholische Musik *
Es hat eine Weile gedauert, bis ich
spürte und verinnerlichen konnte ...
Zumindest denke ich,
dass ich anfangen konnte,
zu verinnerlichen und zu verstehen,
und da reinzuwachsen,
dass dieses Happy
auch Platz haben darf.
"You must happy" - das glaube ich.
Es vergeht kein Tag,
an dem ich mich nicht bewusst
für alles, was ich habe, bedanke.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023